almost every night
revenge' refugees from Myanmar wash up
on the bangladesh coast
[Music]
mara mara TIRR brunette album one day I
never hid
[Music]
due to Mia and his family were driven
from their village by government
soldiers and Buddhist vigilantes on a
deadly rampage the city much diversity
and guru solve our bodies will be my
father nearly Monica did they all make
it out the Cardinal uber launched Amara
Lauren Shah Mardan are never Dean after
launch I want to forgive it aside I did
do more cardio despite having lived in
Myanmar for centuries the government
considers revenge of Muslims to be
illegal immigrants from Bangladesh
Bangladesh embargo for stupid a little
mother money to be everywhere I know a
book did you monetize everything been
lagging Arab annually wouldn't know the
family stops to rest in a market stall
nearby nor begum cradles a newborn son
as she fled her village a bullet grazed
her child's head
what's her baby's name two months ago
these hills on the Bangladesh border
were mostly empty since then more than
600,000 rojan J have flocked here from
Myanmar well over half the countries
were injured ten-year-old firuze Khan
arrived alone after the violence claimed
his
[Music]
it took four days of walking and the
dangerous river crossing to reach
Bangladesh the rojan Joe have been
called the world's most persecuted
minority authorities in Myanmar keep
them in apartheid light conditions
restricting their movement access to
health care and education it was no
surprise that years of abuse and neglect
led to a violent reaction in October
2016 our hinge a militant group known as
the era Conroe hinges salvation army
attacked three police outposts killing
nine officers on August 25th of this
year our so fighters struck again this
time the attack backfired catastrophic
Allah
government forces and vigilantes
responded with a campaign of
indiscriminate killing mass rape and
arson that the UN is calling a textbook
example of ethnic cleansing every day
new refugees slog toward makeshift camps
their possessions are few children
ripped from their parents and thrown
into fires alive or being hacked to
death
in front of their parents horrific
stories of rape women being raped by
Burmese soldiers and then beaten
unconscious and put into homes that are
then set on fire
really the the I've been doing this for
twenty years and some of the stories
have documented in the last few weeks
have been the most shocking of my career
and this is part of a deliberate
systematic campaign of ethnic cleansing
by the Myanmar military yes for the last
month day after day after day the
Burmese army has been arriving in these
villages they just start opening fire on
the people in these villages and once
the people have left they burn down
their homes nearly three hundred row
hinge of villages in Rakhine State have
been raised since the crisis began
forcing a mass exodus into Bangladesh
satellite imagery confirms the scale of
the destruction this has been happening
for a month now and there's just no end
in sight the Burmese army is not going
to stop this campaign of ethnic
cleansing until the last row hanga has
been pushed out of Burma that's very
clearly routine sorry Gordon
sorry God Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
Allah this year my own immediate aside
the Parata
[Music]
firuze is one of thousands of orphans
now living in the camps thank you thank
you video being honest my
[Music]
or even in a row hanger ball already
firuze may have to wait a long time
before this latest crisis Bangladesh
already hosted about 300,000 Ranjha
displaced by previous outbreaks of
violence some live lived here for over
two decades Bangladesh has long been
reluctant to register Ong as refugees on
the hope they would one day return home
the flood of another half million people
and Counting is testing its lands today
they have come around two thousand and
Easter Day around 5,000 people came and
this is actually there is no hunger
camps here this is a landing point for
them we organize them we give them the
basic need basic relief as you can see
and there are some stock and then we
added the vehicle for them this will
take them to up to the or moving again
there are many camps in the inside the
city of digne Bangladesh is a relatively
poor country do you feel like you can
continue to provide this kind of support
to the refugees if they keep coming I
think without these people really I feel
for them where is your husband they say
most of them either captured or killed
something like
do Tamiya and his family somehow manage
to stay together
they're no longer being hunted but their
journey's end is still a hard day's
travel away
[Music]
hey this is Jason Mott leg with aj+
thanks for watching for one of our
documentary and wanted to continue
watching click on part two above be sure
to subscribe here for more documentaries
like this